Aaron let me start about start with last
night with whatever went on by the way
Aaron will be joined by Dan Schulman and
Jessica Mendoza Buster Olney for ESPN's
exclusive presentation of the nice
League wild card game tonight at 8:00
Eastern what are you thinking as you're
watching the Blue Jays in the 11th
inning with Zach Britton in the bullpen
I would say at that point I was a little
stunned
I had no issue up to that point up to
the 11th inning with the way it unfolded
because the Orioles have a great bullpen
and I think they used all their pieces
properly when I saw Brian Duensing on
the mound to start the 11th inning at
first I thought it was Britton just
because I saw a left-handed pitcher and
I thought okay yeah this heat feels like
the right time to bring him out you got
to top the order when I saw it with
Duensing I kind of went okay he's gonna
try and piece this thing together again
when he retired Carrera now you've got
Donaldson and Carr nación and Bautista
coming up I was I was frankly very
surprised that they went to a ball dough
in that situation just because you know
even though he's been pitching well of
late it's still he's coming into a
situation that he hasn't really been in
out of the bullpen he's been a guy that
historically when he has issues its
command related and you really want to
avoid that in that situation but I
thought okay he's pushed all the right
buttons at this point and as soon as the
first hit happened I thought okay you
got to go get Britt this is the time
then another hit goes by and then I see
him go out to the mound I'm thinking
okay now you you definitely need Britton
who's a master at getting the ball on
the ground you really need a double play
ball here either within car nación or
with Bautista so look at the risk of
piling on and I have mad respect for
Buck Showalter I thought it was a huge
blunder to not have written in that game
at any point in the 11th I just looked
at those three hitters and and you have
to get through that group there to live
to see another inning and that
that's what surprised me where they
didn't bring him in and the fact the
guys given up one run since the start of
May Aaron you know I mean that's that's
why I own candidate it it's stunning
it's stunning that he doesn't get into
that game you know and it's going to be
a question that buck is going to
probably have to answer for the rest of
his life unfortunately that the you know
like you said a scion candidate doesn't
get in that game at the 11th inning
point of the game you would think he
would have had at least two innings
maybe more in the tank for him giving
your team even more ample time to score
and if you can't win it in 13 innings at
that point then you try and piece it
together you saw there was a beer bottle
thrown during that game by somebody one
of the Toronto fans have you ever had
stuff thrown at you when you play yeah
not has nothing that sticks out like
that but sure you've had minor things
happen like that I mean that's that's
incredibly unfortunate and hopefully you
know just a little reminder that you
know all these teams right now all these
stadiums parks that we're about to go in
hopefully it just you know raised a
little red flag or a little light goes
on that hey we got to make sure we're
absolutely buttoned up you know from a
security standpoint you know from having
our cameras set up and and being able to
you know really do away with these kind
of things and hopefully the guy I don't
know but follow up but hopefully the guy
that did it you know was caught his
prosecutors not allowed into stadiums
and and you know when you come down hard
on those things hopefully that that can
add as a deterrent as well yeah I think
you should be punished and not allowed
to drink beer the rest of his life here
what do you think Aaron boon to the
mothership tonight they'll have the
Giants and the Mets you got syndergaard
against Bumgarner
you would expect a pitching duel here
what could tip the balance here when you
have a a winner-take-all situation well
I'll be keeping an eye on the pitch
count
you would think on the giant side with
Bumgarner it's not a real issue
I mean if Bumgarner is thrown throwing
well I mean I think we could all
conceivably see him going 130 maybe more
pitches than that if he's pitching well
so so you don't really worry about him
if he's on his game getting deep into
the game with cinder guard those pitch
counts at times have been an issue and I
think going up against this Giants
lineup not a juggernaut not by any means
offensively but the one thing they do
well is they put the ball in play and
they don't and they and they walk so
they're not striking out and they walk
which is kind of a unique combination so
I think it's going to be imperative for
syndergaard when he's ahead in the count
so when he's o2 when he's old one when
he's one two
not getting too many counts where it
goes to 3 2 being content with
challenging these guys in the strike
zone and if that means in contact so be
it but not having no fear of that I
think that gives him a chance to go
deeper in the game and then when he has
runners on base the stolen base has been
a huge issue for syndergaard 48 stolen
bases against him this year yikes the
Giants you know don't run a lot dunya is
probably not in the lineup for the
Giants though but look for the Giants if
they get some opportunities to try and
kind of force the issue a little bit on
the bases especially because obviously
they're not a team that hits the ball
out of the ballpark a lot baumgartner's
personality on the mound how would you
describe that fiery prickly ego-driven
prickly is a good one yeah and and
that's the case for him and in hearing
him talk yesterday and knowing him a
little bit you know nothing really
for him whether it's a spring training
game in March in Scottsdale or tonight's
game I mean that's the way he is when
he's between the line he's very
competitive at times you know you know I
the Bleak situation the other a couple
weeks ago I felt like was entirely
Bumgarner's issue fault and actually may
have cost the Giants in that situation
but there's no denying that it's a big
factor in who he is and a big factor I
think in his success yeah I agree I
don't know who else you face that had a
demeanor like that Randy Johnson could
be that way on the bound but I don't
know if there's somebody else that you
see Bumgardner and you've already
experienced that as a player yeah you
know Randy Johnson I guess comes to mind
but but I think they're a little
different personality in that Randy when
when he was playing was a lot more
reserved and closed off whereas
Bumgarner's a little more you know you
know slickly outgoing you know even in
his kind of dry understated way but from
a demeanor from a competitive standpoint
I think that's a fair comparison and and
actually from the repertoire standpoint
I have fun tonight Aaron thank you for
joining us we appreciate it thank you
thanks for having me on that's Aaron
Boone the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience